it's time now for cbs morning's deals
and this week we have some items that
may help people save some time with
those household chores and they might
just become essentials in your everyday
life to start shopping go ahead and scan
that qr code on your screen do it right
now you can also go to
cbsdeals.com this morning lifestyle host
gail bass joins us with some gadgets
that may help simplify your home and
upgrade your home office good morning
good morning it's so good to be here i
have some stuff that you guys are going
to love especially you because you've
got teenagers at home and you because
you've got a grandbaby now when they get
messy the huvie by caloric is what
you're going to want because it takes
the work out of vacuum you're talking
about this rosie the robot from the
jetsons is here in the form of this
that's what i love about it gail i
thought this was a scale no it's not a
scale
i don't do scales okay no no no no no i
don't have scales only first thing in
the morning without a meal all right so
all you do is you download the app and
then you turn it on and if once you turn
it on uh-huh you'll hear it and it'll
start moving and there it goes oh
wait somebody dropped cereal what's
gonna happen
okay
wow
that's pretty fantastic so it doesn't
just vacuum it also cleans the air it
cleans the air it does have a air
purifier and this is great for people
who have mobility issues or let's just
say you're having people for cocktails
and you want the household really
cleaned up really quick if you aren't
there it also has like a place where you
can put a little bit of scent so it can
sent the house so you have a little
aroma diffuser but this is about
convenience you can schedule your
cleaning this can connect to your smart
devices so you can say hey okay alexa
okay google do what you need to do so
are you guiding it though yeah how does
it know where to go because it's
bouncing right there that was just a
straight line bounces around on its own
it knows where to i let it go and it
didn't scare my dog like my regular
vacuum cleaner so we have this this is a
great deal we have it for
199.99 that's 50 off you guys were
talking about 200 off for this deal okay
does it work on carpets too yes it does
work on carpets too okay so you brought
carpets because that's a that's also a
problem i think nate's kids are potty
trained and employed or they're potty
trained in school but a baby is not
potty trained oh this is all sorts of
stains this is perfect for people who
have pets who have little babies that
are putting cereal on the floor or
somebody spills wine this is the my
magic carpet i love it my dog loves it
he sleeps on it i do yoga on it this
thing is fantastic for kids who are
going away to college right now because
this rug is washable see somebody can
spill wine on this thing you can put it
in your standard washing machine and
dryer and wash it this is something that
i've done multiple times i have one at
home and i use it it is great you take
it out you roll it out this is great for
the dorm room this is great for the
guest room somebody coming in the door
they're tracking in mud put in the mud
room
perfect and i took it on a picnic i took
it to a pool party i put in the back of
the car because i hike a lot this is so
useful here comes gail with her rug yes
but why does your dog love it you said
my your dog loves a vacuum cleaner your
dog loves a rug what's the dog's name
his name is walter he's named after
walter cronkite yes really yes he is yes
he is
yes he is and walter really is likes the
tile uh because i'm in the desert so he
likes the cool tile sometimes but
sometimes he likes being on a rug so you
know he's it's he's the band of the
house he picks where he wants to go what
kind of dog is he i'm just kidding he's
a pitbull mix he's a watchdog he's named
after walmart he's not a watchdog
oh he's not you can walk in the house
right now he just said give me a treat
i'll show you where everything is
what i love about it
gail's over there the price of this
starts at 39.99 we haven't forgotten
about we have multiple sizes you saw you
saw that one we have a round shag rug we
have multiple designs oh you got a shoe
yeah there's a shag which a washable
shack think about it
how great is that are people still doing
challenges yeah
i'll send you a picture very comfortable
on a hot day you lie down on it i don't
know walter loves mine does he okay
all right i'm over here thinking i'm
going to log on to my email right we
have a standing desk attachment and i
actually use the standing desk in my
office yeah tell me about this this is
the work easy best and what's great
about this is this is also great for
kids who are going away for college or
people who don't watch
television anymore they watch their
tablets or you can use this in the
kitchen or the cooking room but this is
just great for students if they can set
up their desk wherever they want or
people working from home so many people
are still working from home at least a
couple of times a week so this is
something that you can use as your desk
it's portable it's adjustable you make
it good for you and what's great about
the work easy best is that you could sit
on your couch you could be on the bed
you could be on your my magic carpet in
the park using this to do your work
does walter use that too gail that's it
it's a posture thing i walk into my kids
rooms and they're they're they're all
unstoppable yeah their neck is all bent
up yeah exactly i can have something
like that laying right on top of them in
the bed doing their work but tony
actually uses this too yeah and you like
it posture lower back i feel like i stay
awake and attentive longer if i'm
upright like this thank you exactly on
your feet uh what does this run this one
is 21.50 we have a deal on this one
right now but we also have the cd42
which is 11.50
all right for somebody going away two
girls are better than one yeah
i appreciate it
to purchase anything that you saw today
scan the qr code on your screen right
now you can also visit cbsdeals.com